dozens of you wrote to me
about the neo-nazis openly demonstrating
in florida in orlando florida
it is absolutely wild what is going on
down there and it's another reminder
that you know it's it it pains me that
among some
on the left
uh jews are seen as a privileged group
that is not a minority
targeted by so many different
right-wing and sometimes unfortunately
left-wingers as well
but we should not allow that to become
the dominant perspective among the left
because it is just flat-out wrong
as officials denounce nazi rallies in
orlando
desantis accuses political opponents
of smear what
neo-nazi demonstrators in orlando over
the weekend drew bipartisan
condemnations but governor ron desantis
remained silent until monday afternoon
when he responded to questions about the
rallies with a tirade
against his political enemies rather
than against the neo-nazis
so what i'm going to say is these people
these democrats
who are trying to use this some type of
political issue to try to smear me as if
i had something to do with that we're
not playing their game
well what about denouncing the neo-nazis
he referred to the demonstrators a group
of about 20 shouting anti-semitic slurs
while waving nazi flags
as some jackasses doing this on the
street and said they would be held
accountable
but he also accused democrats who called
for him to denounce the neo-nazis of
exploiting the demonstrations now they
just want you to denounce the neo-nazis
it's very simple here's some video um of
this
bizarre and disgusting event
so that was hail hitler and what he did
it can be hard to hear and if you're not
watching there's swastikas everywhere
they're doing the um hail hitler salute
as well they're dressed in sort of like
um
man is it is it sort of like ss larping
uh
i i don't know
white power
so six million viewers referring to six
million jews dead in the holocaust and
doing the heil hitler salute
white pride is when you think it white
power is when you live it that's another
nice little phrase
[Music]
so i think that wow uh that was your we
can tell you're a jew from how close
together your eyes are
you effing k
i'm ready
[Laughter]
[Applause]
rabbi does
so um
this is the united states folks this is
the united states and this is not only
demonstrations i think it's important
that we remember
that this is the sort of
cartoonish outburst of it but that we
are continuing to see stories like this
one out of chicago synagogues vandalized
and damaged hours apart in west rogers
park and lincolnwood
multiple synagogues vandalized or
damaged just miles apart sunday in
chicago and lincolnwood someone
spray-painted graffiti on a synagogue in
west devon video shows a hate symbol
with spray painted on the backside of
the synagogue someone spray-painted
graffiti on a cargo container about a
block away hours earlier a man was seen
on video kicking out the side window of
a synagogue in lincolnwood
unclear if the incidents are related
and uh alderwoman deborah silverstein
said vandalism was discovered at several
local jewish institutions and businesses
we want to make sure we stay on top of
this because unfortunately
that i say this with peace and love
too many
of my progressive brethren brothers and
sisters
um are not keyed in to the anti-semitism
they write it off with some very typical
sort of phylo-semitic tropes that i've
talked about before and um
i don't i don't want to see that
so we're we're going to stay on top of
this whatever other shows do i can't
tell you but we're going to be staying
on top of this
we have a voicemail number that number
is
to david p
um before i play today's voicemail uh if
anyone in the audience works for rivian
the electric car
maker
uh
please get in touch info davidpakman.com
we have uh we have an idea we'd like to
talk to someone from from rivien about
uh so if you work at rivian the electric
car manufacturer info davidpakman.com